- On this episode I talk about wholesale,
sins of my employees,
my favorite curse word
and I announce the three winners.
(upbeat rhythmic music)
You ask questions
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 121
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm in a very good mood.
It's a Friday, it's gorgeous out.
It's Madelena's birthday.
I don't know if you can get there, D Rock,
it's her birthday.
She's 40 years old today.
It's tremendous.
Happy 40th, Madelena.
I get to announce the
winners of the contest
which means one week from today,
three of you, from the Vayner Nation,
will come here and
replace India and Staphon
and DRock, figure it out
DRock, figure it out.
And Steve.
Somebody, oh, is he here?
Oh, is it, no.
Somebody's lazy on Fridays.
And I'm looking forward to that.
I'm also wearing a tremendous,
custom made Jets shirt from
Chris H, from HC Prints.
Oh, threads, excuse me,
let's not screw that up, bro.
I don't want to ruin it for you.
HC Threads from Texas, I
appreciate it, brother.
I saw the whole like,
making of it on Instagram.
It was popping up.
I knew it was coming, but
I figured the t-shirts
would just get lost in the mail
like so much else gets lost
and I'm glad we made it happen.
Probably because you were
involved India instead of DeMayo.
And so, what else is going on?
I'm heading out to see
the family which is great.
Really looking forward to this weekend.
Good solid week of work, very busy.
A couple of shows.
We really were only scheduled for one,
but we got in three this week.
That is what you call
hustle, Vayner Nation.
So, we're gonna save and build up
to the announcement at
the end of the show.
So, India, let's get into
the show.
Show.
- [India] John asks, "What
is your favorite swear word
"of all time?"
- John, my favorite swear
word of all time is dickface.
There's something about
dickface that really, really,
you know, I don't know why, but
like, I think when I use it,
people just really, like,
actually, I've never really
even thought about the
word until just right now
and I mean, it's pretty self explanatory.
- [India] I thought you
were gonna say dickface.
- You thought I was gonna say dickface?
- Yeah, you say dickface a lot.
- I do say dickface a lot.
India, that's a very interesting
strategy to start the show.
You know, kinda feel like,
you know, the show's growing
very quickly and you can
imagine there's a lot of people
who are watching for the
very, very first time.
That's a pretty aggressive
move on question number one
of all time watching
the #AskGaryVee show.
So, welcome newbies.
- [India] Daniel asks,
"As a guy who loves hustle
"and people, what is the unforgivable sin
"one of your employees could make?"
- What's the unforgivable
sin that one of my employ,
I mean, actually there's a lot
of things that I really think
are very important to me in
like, not lines in the sand,
but you know, what's
interesting is, it's funny,
hustle and people, I'm
not worried about people's
work ethic, you know it's funny, actually
I've been thinking about DRock, Staphon,
I've been thinking about
making a video, actually
about hustle may be my super power, right,
but it doesn't have to be yours.
Right back to everybody's
strength and weaknesses.
Mine just, you know, I'm
a little bit concerned
that a lot of you who are watching this,
you know, you hear my mantra
of hard work, 24/7/365,
and you start trying
to force yourself into
going into that direction
and really I'm just
speaking to the small group
of people that are watching
or listening to the show
that actually have that skill
of being able to, when they're passionate,
work their faces off and that is
one of the competitive advantages.
One of my favorites,
mine, in a lot of ways,
but it doesn't have to be yours.
So, you know, it's funny
how the question was asked
because I think it's a leading question
to, you know, if they only
work like Steve, right,
you know, if they work
like Steve here, right.
So, you know, that's not
the issue at hand at all.
I think the only sin and the
quickest way to get fired
from VaynerMedia is to
not figure out a way
to play nice with the other boys and girls
that you work with.
To me, the number one thing that I judge
VaynerMedia employees
on is how they interact
with every other VaynerMedia employee.
Some people in the
organization are really good
at leading their teams.
They have 12, 15 people and
their team loves them to death
and they love their team to death.
However, cross department,
if they're on account
with creative or with
the paid team or with IT
or the video production
team, they're not as good.
They're fighting just for their team
and they're burning bridges
in those departments.
Not good.
Other people are tremendous with clients
and are great with the
other senior people,
but they're not treating the people
underneath them with the respect
and their team doesn't
love working for them
or micromanaging them and so.
You know, managing styles don't bother me.
People have to learn their
cadence on micromanaging
versus giving people air
cover, but being disrespectful
or being selfish to what's
in your best interest,
not the logo's interest as a
whole, within the organization,
to me, is just completely unacceptable.
Letting your emotions get the
best of you and talking down
to somebody or creating
conflict, unacceptable.
So, those are the things
that are the sins within my environment.
And so damn true, right?
- [India] Let's go to video.
- Video.
- We have two videos today.
- Two videos today.
- Hey Gary, Aaron Pearson
here in Allen, Texas.
I got a quick question for you.
- A lot of Texas love.
- What has been the
largest or biggest failure
you've had either in
your business or in life,
that's propelled you forward
towards the most success?
Also, I hope to see you next week
as I film the #GaryVeeShow with you.
Thanks.
- That's a great job, Aaron.
Sorry you lost.
Great question, love the video.
You know I think, you
know, I've been lucky.
I think the one failure I've had was
that 2009 to 2011 window
where I was trying to be
Gary Vee, 'cause of Crush It!.
I was running Wine Library.
We started VaynerMedia.
Misha was just born.
I was trying to do Obsessed TV.
I was trying to do the wine
social network, Cork'd.
I was trying to do the
social network for developers
and designers called Forrst.
And I was very stretched thin.
I was investing.
And so, I learned that I
was trying to definitely
put my ass on too many toilets.
That's a Russian translation
for all you Ruskies out there,
you know exactly what I'm talking about.
And so, I wasn't able
to balance all of that.
And even now, I really, I
feel like I'm starting to
take on a lot of stuff.
The difference is, I did
a better job up front.
There was more selective of the people
that I've partnered with
on Resy and Faithbox
and BRaVe ventures.
And this has nothing
to do with the Obsessed
or Forrst or Cork'd team.
I picked partners that I needed to provide
too many things to, besides
capital, and made those promises
so, it's my failure, not theirs.
This time around I found
people who had skills
that were more similar to mine.
I also have dramatically
more infrastructure
with VaynerMedia and my team.
And so, you know, DRock's
helped out with Faithbox,
you know, and so, you know
Zak has helped out with BRaVe.
You know, everybody's helped
out a little bit here with Resy
you know, so there's,
that's really it my man.
I've been very, very, very lucky.
I think for the most
part, I think in only,
you know, this is the reason
I struggled with yesterday's
question with what I
don't like about myself.
I think there's something
interesting in the way
that I process, that I'm really
getting deeper into myself
through this show, through your comments.
Just really, really gathering
a lot of pieces right now.
And what I've realized is wow,
I am really a net net guy.
I mean, if you think about all the things
that are not working
in my world right now,
there's a ton, there's a ton
of shit not working out there.
Different initiatives,
different departments, a ton.
But I can't help but not
recognize that we're gonna grow,
you know, outrageously this year
and be massively successful.
And so, there's probably
tons of flaws with me
from yesterday's question.
I'm just not capable of seeing them
because in a net net
game, I'm a decent dude.
And so, one thing that I
would implore and one thing
I would challenge and one thing I would
actually want so many of you to shift into
is why are you allowing
yourself to look at every
small loss along the way?
Instead of taking a step back
and looking at, minimally, a year.
You know, preferably a five year window
and say, have you won in that environment?
And so, who cares if you,
you know how many
investments I've lost on?
You know, like, in the last two years,
you know how many
employees didn't work out?
You know how many flights I took
that took up a lot of time
that materialized into nothing?
You know how many negative
comments I've gotten
about this show?
You're allowing yourself, and
this is based on your DNA,
so listen, if you need
to go speak to somebody
and lay on a couch.
If you need to write and express yourself.
Find your way to level up your ability
to look at things at a net
score versus the minutia
from a day to day, week
to week, month to month
loss game and I promise you, you will have
a happier and more
successful career slash life.
- [India] Jay asks, "If you're
in a wholesale business,
"where volume is more
important than content,
"how would you take
advantage of social media?"
- Jay, what's the matter with you?
Volume's more important
than content everywhere
because volume of selling shit
is what you do for a living.
Regardless if you sell
weird looking statues
or phones or, I love taking off, kicks.
You know, like, volume always matters.
Content is a liaison
to more volume, right.
My content wasn't more
important on Wine Library TV.
It was the fact that that
lead to selling stuff.
And so, whether you're
in wholesale or retail,
or B to B or B to C, the
end goal within the context,
is to drive a result including
if you're non-profit.
You're not making content
that's gonna make somebody cry
about, you know, the dogs in
the wild that we need to save
because you just want somebody to cry.
No, you want them to
take out their wallet,
this is what you want, Jay.
You want them to take out their wallet
and give them the cash.
Right, that's what you want.
And so, please don't
get it twisted, anybody,
that so much of this is predicated on
how do you provide that value to then
have leverage to get the
result that you're looking for?
And so, sorry India, it got
a little bit heated there
for a second.
Word it for me one more time.
- [India] He says, "Your
wholesale business where
"volume is more important than content,
"how would you take
advantage of social media?"
- Yeah, I mean, no I
mean, you know, you know.
First of all, when you're
in wholesale, you're in the
B to B business, so you
have it easy, in my opinion.
Go and map who your customers are.
Go to Facebook.
Run ads against the
companies of the people
you're trying to reach.
Employees of the company
you are trying to sell this.
Go run it against Foot Locker employees.
People that work at Foot Locker.
Do you guys have Facebook accounts?
I feel like people haven't
been updating them as well,
but the data's still incredible at scale.
This is just a quick test.
Do any of you put
VaynerMedia in your profile?
- [Voiceover] Mm hmm.
- All five of you?
Even better than I thought.
You can reach all five of these characters
by targeting employees of VaynerMedia.
As a matter of fact,
somebody could have probably
been flown in next Friday
if they were smart enough
to spend $40, 40 measly dollars on ads
against VaynerMedia employees,
where they used the VaynerMedia employees
to pressure me to bring that person,
but you didn't, you just didn't.
And so, execution my friends
and being a practitioner
is always, always better
than headline reading.
And so, I will tell you it is very easy.
LinkedIn, Facebook, target
your actual customer
and then make content
that is valuable to them.
Right?
Which means different than B to C.
So, back to this.
I'm a sneaker producer.
I'm new, I've got to compete
with Under Armour, Nike
and Reebok and Puma and crap.
Maybe my ad is, hey, introducing
the new Gary sneaker.
More profitable for you than the others.
Like literally, it is a
B to B promotion, right.
Like, here's a chart.
This is what you make on
all these other characters.
Sure, they bring people in,
but here's my offer and
I'm able to bring you
dramatically more profit and as a kicker,
if you email me back, I
will also run ad dollars
directly to your store for my sneaker
because you're one of
the first hundred people
to contact me.
I'm a businessman.
That's how my brain thinks.
- [India] Simon Sinek.
- Simon Sinek?
Simon, my man!
Such a good dude.
A lot of people love him.
A lotta people.
You guys know him?
He's the best.
You guys are about to love him.
He's unbelievable.
- Hey Gary, Simon Sinek
here, hope you're well.
- I'm well, Simon.
- I have a question about social media.
As you know, I'm a humanist
and I'm really big into human beings,
hanging out with human beings
and building real relationships.
- Me too, Simon.
- And I love technology
and I love social media,
but I'm also aware that there's a balance
and if things go out of
balance, it can actually hurt
the relationships that we form.
And it's amazing for me
sometimes to watch people
you know, every notification they get,
their Instagram, their
Facebook, their Twitter,
everything that shows up
on the top of their phones,
they can't help but look
down and see what's going on.
My question to you is, do you think that
companies who use social
media as a primary means
of marketing, or any means of
marketing, for that matter,
have a responsibility to actually
help us find that balance?
Do they have a responsibility
to help us manage
our real relationships or is it entirely
the responsibility of the user?
Thanks for your help.
- Simon, first of all,
since we're buddies,
I'm dying to have dinner.
Let's get together, 'cause I'm
gonna ask you questions like,
do you think that it's the responsibility
of New York City to
limit the size of sodas
or is it the responsibility for us?
Do you think it's the responsibility
of McDonald's to no longer make anything
that is over 180 calories or
is it the responsibility of us?
Do we think that we should, you know,
and it's a very, very
slippery slope, right,
I mean, I think that
politicians and other humans
have for a long time tried to say,
we know what's better for the user
than the user themselves.
Not to mention, in a business environment,
as you know, Simon, you know,
Dunkin' Donuts and
Starbucks and Peet's Coffee
can be like, cool, we're gonna do this.
We're gonna limit, we're gonna only Tweet
and post on Instagram three times a day.
And then like, Gary's
Coffee's gonna swoop in
and do it all day long and
see results in the white space
and then the other companies were like,
screw that, we're back.
And so, I think it's an
interesting question.
I also think, and this
gives me an opportunity
to go there, Simon, to say the following.
I promise you that when you and I
go and have these drinks
or dinner in a couple weeks
that I will rarely look
at my phone, if at all.
You know why?
'Cause you're interesting.
'Cause I like you.
'Cause I don't see you that often.
And because that's what I want to be doing
when I'm there.
On the flip side, if me
and Staphon were just going
to hang out right now for a quick coffee,
I might look at my
phone a couple of times.
I get to see him more often.
We don't have that much to
talk about right this second.
You know, and so I'm like,
I'm gonna be choosing
what I want to do besides
what I'm doing right there.
I think that us people looking at phones.
Looking at notifications is
actually a true indicator
of what we value.
You know, about to take
a drive with my mom,
will not be looking at my phone so much
'cause I miss my mom
and I want to hang out.
But if I saw my mom every single day,
I promise you I probably would.
Which is the truth.
It's just us choosing what we want.
And so, technology has given us options.
You know, I always talk about the couple
you see in a restaurant, where like,
me and Lizzie will walk in.
Well, me and Lizzie don't talk about this
'cause of my point of view, but I know
so many of you have
walked into a restaurant
and you've seen a couple and literally,
both of them are on the
phone the whole time.
And you and your partner are having dinner
and saying like, look
how sad that is, right.
All of you have done that.
Or at least you've heard
of somebody doing that
or you've been part of a party.
To me, I don't think that people
recognize that same couple,
20 years ago, they just sat
and ate dinner in silence
looking at each other.
Have you seen that weird thing?
Have you seen that weird thing, India?
Yeah, it's weird.
- It was weird.
- It's weird so I actually
am happy for that couple
because what they would
have had to do 20 years ago,
which is sit there in silence,
they're at least actually
keeping up with the ball game.
Looking up on their Instagram.
Deciding what they'd
rather do in that moment
than hang out with the other person
because they don't have a great marriage
or great relationship.
That's just real.
This is real dynamics.
I think it's a very
dangerous slope to say,
look, all these
relationships, how sad is this
human interaction when
you have absolutely zero,
triple zero, not double
zero, Robert Parrish,
triple zero, follow me here DRock.
Triple zero context to
what's actually going on
in the relationship.
Do you know how many
people, I got it DRock.
people are in you know,
out in public with each
other that hate each other
at that moment.
That are struggling.
That are having problems.
That are on the verge of breaking up.
That have a business issue at hand.
There's so many dynamics
and I have no interest
in sitting on a pedestal and saying,
they should be interacting
with each other.
And so, yeah, I think
there's a responsibility
and I think the responsibility goes
in many different directions.
And I think it's a tremendously
interesting question.
I still think that ultimately,
it's very difficult
to do anything other than
to rely on the end user
to do what's best for her or him.
And so, that's kind of
where I sit on the issue.
Cool, good show.
Simon, I really appreciate it.
Vayner Nation, if you
don't know who Simon is,
please look him up.
I'm an enormous, enormous fan.
I think he's a tremendous human being.
It's really funny, I
think, by the way, we agree
on so, so damn much, so much.
I really enjoy him.
And I very much just
want everybody to know
I believe tremendously
in human interaction.
I believe technology is
the greatest gateway drug
to more human interaction.
There's no question in my life,
not even an ounce of doubt,
that over the, if I look at the
last three years of my life,
the time that I've spent with
people, that I would never
in a million years had those
moments just a decade earlier
because there was no
infrastructure of technology
to be the liaison to
make those events happen.
I think it's very easy and
simple to look at technology
as taking away from those events.
I think it is clear to me,
I hope to be right long term
on this issue, it is clear
to me that it is actually
expanding our ability to
spend more time with people.
I really believe that.
I believe that you're in
more constant, I mean,
just sit for five seconds and think about
all the high school and college friends
that your older brothers or
parents never had the chance,
or me, never had the chance
of staying in touch with.
I'm perfect age.
If you're in my age, 38
to 42, think about those
first 10 years out of
school where we lost touch
with all our friends and
then Facebook came along
and we reconnected and all
the times I've been able
to hang out now with T
Adam Blum and Ken Scelfo
and Mike Eisenhardt,
like these are moments
that would have, Mike
and Lindsay Eisenhardt
came and had dinner with
me, downstairs a year ago.
I would have never seen them again.
That night meant so much to me.
Reminiscing about high school things
that I never thought of.
So, I think it's very, very simple.
Very, very, very simple.
Very, very simple to blame technology
and think it's taking away.
I think it's enabling.
Flipside.
Announce the winners?
- [India] Yeah.
- Should announce some winners, huh?
Alright, India, I know we have
a tremendous gentleman from Vermont.
- [India] We do.
- I know we have an immigrant.
- [India] Webly.
- Yes, from Haiti, I think.
And a lovely young man, Dallas,
who actually I met in L.A., so.
You know, I gotta tell you a good story.
I met Dallas in L.A. for the
talk I gave the other day
and he said something to me
like I'm gonna win the contest
and many people have
said that to me already
for the last week and
I was like, yeah okay.
Really, I mean like, not in a bad way.
I'm a good guy, I'm like,
let's see, he's an awesome dude
and I met his brother,
Austin and then I made a joke
of like, where's your sister, Houston?
And then they said our mom
said if we had another brother,
it'd be Tyler and so.
But he won.
Pretty impressive, I've
gotta give him daps.
So, Dallas.
- [India] Dallas, Matthew.
- Matthew.
- [India] From Vermont.
- Yep, from Vermont, yes.
- [India] Webly.
- And Webly, I'm massively excited.
I know that Dallas hasn't
gotten back to us yet,
but Matthew and Webly are excited.
- [India] Very excited.
- Let's get with India here, come on.
- They're freaking out.
- Like, did they really freak their shit?
- Yeah, they freaked their shit.
Matthew said, "My
roommates don't understand
"why I'm freaking out right now."
- I love it.
- Where is it?
They were really nice emails.
- India said, "Just closing
my laptop to go out to dinner
"and I saw the email mid close."
Mid close, he saw the email, I love it.
I love it.
- He's in shock.
- I love it.
I'm so excited.
Oh, Webly's got a glamorous picture.
- Yeah, she looks so glam.
- I'm so excited.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
So cool, I'm very, very, very excited.
I think next Friday's
going to be an amazing day.
Question of the day.
What plans do you have for this weekend?
And part two, a little bit more detailed.
What is your latest website obsession?
What is the website or app
that is most catching your
attention that is new to you
in the last 60, 75 days?
You keep asking questions.
I'll keep answering them.
(urgent music)